19 août 9h du matin
non
l'été il faut un bateau pour rendre
visite à jean rochefort
sur l'eau
le soleil tape déjà fort
[Musique]
l'écriture de son livre a repoussé le
rendez-vous de plusieurs mois
pour l'entretien jean a finalement
préféré le sud à paris je l'appelle
depuis le bateau à l'eau gens il est
surpris puis cassant il a zappé le
rendez-vous mauvaise mayonnaise
comme les chevaux sauvages qui te
connais bien jean rochefort est parfois
difficile à approcher
françois son épouse nous a rassuré jean
a mal dormi mais nous attend
salon carrières des fils 150 films 40
pièces des dessins animés des pubs des
réalisations de livres 3 césars bref
jean rochefort bretelles violette et
baskets citron et d'une impressionnante
jeunesse avec une grande faculté des
coûts alors que notre but est plutôt
d'entendre parler de lui parler de son
boulot
je me sentais tellement incapable de
faire quoi que ce soit d'autre que je me
disais simplement être cela ou mourir
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle une
motivation
jusqu alors il avait toujours dit non à
la présence d'une caméra sur son lieu de
vacances nous sommes dans un éden de
chlorophylle un petit lac de verdure
avec des bosquets occupé par une arme
expliqué le lieu est idéal pour parler
vrai pour dit-il secoué le pot-au-feu
recul
[Musique]
le scénario d'une vie peut commencer
si ma vie était un film on y verrait mon
grand père mon père mon petit frère
frankie et moi même à quatre ans à 15
ans à 20 ans
on y verrait ma fille houmous est un
mélange entre peter sellers et james
stewart
avec de l'élégance
de l'émotion écrits du burlesque on a
partagé beaucoup de choses ensemble on
est des amis depuis toujours comme des
frères mieux que les frères
carmine aux les conditions ça va bien si
j'avais un flingue jeu le descendre
[Applaudissements]
mais comment on sait qu'il va me descend
si ma vie et est un film on y verrait
elle
et
moi jambes je me considère vraiment
comme un père spirituel par son humour
son cynisme son décalage qu'il soit vous
trouve très sympathique
l'avait fait forte impression
il est à moi tout ce qui me plaît chez
un homme et pas seulement chez un acteur
pour parler de gens sont des flagorneurs
il suffit de il suffit de dire qu'il est
fêlé
cette folie là
lui permet d'accepter des projets
biscornu
odieux avec santé
[Applaudissements]
il n'est pas lisse ce genre ici c'est
pas un montant qui suit le groupe quoi
c'est pas du tout ça j'aimerais savoir
comment ça se passe au liban créent pas
recommencer avec ça quelle chance de
caresses vous pouvez faire
ça on le voit dans tout ce qu'il est on
le voit dans sa façon de s'habiller on
le voit dans sa façon de s'asseoir va se
lever et de rires de de ne pas
participer à des choses de s'investir
bandeau de la traversée cateau du 4 big
bang est gardée de l'enthousiaste de la
curiosité c'est une chose mode pour moi
je vous admire totalement qui me
j'aimerais bien avoir au 10e
je voulais une femme comme
marc rochet
commune classant sida terre comme un
arbre comme la mer
directeur de la nature
j'ai poursuivi ça toute ma vie
pour toi il ya quelque chose de à la
fois de flamboyant
d'enfantin des majestueux de magistrales
venture d'un côté
si ma vie était un film ce serait votre
prochain film
[Musique]
mon enfance
était en dessin au départ c'était pas le
costume qui m'intéressait c'était
d'être un chat de recevoir un un but
digne de 30 étages sur le boul macke
permet même envoyé vers le ciel
j'étais amoureux fous des dessins animés
pour parer sur douteux nostalgie
existentielle et avec ma mère aussi qui
a été importante bourse à la radio pour
écouter dans noir des retransmissions
théâtre dans une pièce on province où
vivent de tous et par tous
on entendait quand les acteurs se
déplacer sur la scène le trac mans du
plancher
l'acteur s'il osait sa réplique des
silences dont on ne peut laisser pas
sens exact puisque on ne voyait pas donc
c'était de nous plus aventis
s'était exclu
une enfance voyageuse dans les valises
du père cadre dans l'industrie
pétrolière
dinard nantes bordeaux vichy ajoutant un
point d'ancrage breton ici pour les
vacances à saint lunaire gens à 18 ans
c'est le temps des copains des jolies
filles des bombes anatomiques dit il
déjà il est au centre de l'attention et
des rires
la comédie
phonographe de plage amour d'été et
fleurs en bateau la caméra 8 mm de
jacques citroën va sauver jean de la
sévérité paternel
je
son oxygène est bien là dans les
nombreux personnages qu'ils interprètent
tout naturellement
doux mélange de la poésie de jacques
tati
et du burlesque de buster keaton
[Musique]
e
m
talent évident il doit se lancer mais
repousse toujours le moment comment
pêcher par le doute
alors que vous dites est en permanence
je crois
l'angoissent le mal-être est
indispensable aussi bien pour faire
pleurer pour servir et je doute
c'est un moteur ces hommes auteurs
objectif devenir comédien contre l'avis
du père qui le comparent toujours à
pierre son fer polytechnicien à son tour
jean doit réussir direction paris gare
montparnasse en wagon de troisième
classe
[Musique]
nous sommes au début des années 50 de la
bohème partager avec son ami besson qui
deviendra dessinateur de presse
c'est le temps des viols mal chauffés
perdu dans les étages et des maigres
repas surtout
je vais pas plu révisé à lyon a
tellement maintenant autour de nous mais
enfin j'ai passé un réveillon avec un
copain un peintre à regarder une vitrine
de charcuterie les tranches de voulgézac
team et les bûches
et ça nourrit pas pour autant fait durer
le poids pour le recevons
beaucoup de jeunes artistes pour le
cacher dans les différents cabarets de
la ville les places sont rares
jean a la chance de se produire aux
trois baudets place de tichy il y côtoie
le jeune comique fernand raynaud qui
livre ici ses premiers sketches gens
partagent la loge en fumée de l'ami
jacques brel dans le répertoire est
encore limitée
quand on n'a que l'amour
pouvait que partage site avec succès
énorme et puis un jour je leur gueule je
lui ai dit écoute travail ecoutez jean
s'est assise au dallage les jours aux
côtés des abdos dit fais des chansons de
hilal répondu ça ne m'intéresse pas moi
je veux être reporté à la télé parce que
la télévision une autre génération était
persuadée qu'elle ait changé nous
étions persuadés que connaissant les
autres nous pourrions plus les tuer
le raisonnement fantin
résolument que des fois on y croyait dur
comme fer
septembre 1951 le conservatoire après
les cours de la rue blanche et 18 mois
de service militaire
un premier choc le brio de l'élève
marielle qui joue nero gens
est convaincu d'être au bon endroit avec
ses nouveaux copains
belmondo riche kremer marielle annie
girardot françoise fabian michel beaune
pierre vernier
le second choc c'est ce ciment d'amitié
qui exclut toute jalousie
d'où sortent aux aguets vivre déjà était
une merveille
ce bourdonnement monter sur une scène et
s'amuser avec des copains c'était une
merveille ça vient toujours après les
grandes bouches vis à
l'envi leur vie d'être avec les autres
qui ont survécu la rivalité
n'existe vraiment pas vraiment pas leur
époque était complètement différente il
y avait une insouciance il y avait un
esprit de groupe un esprit de solidarité
comme ça de
qui perdure je les vois entre eux ils se
sont branchés sur des shins une érosion
des trucs le voulions garder un esprit
d'amateurs par rapport à cette
profession est de garder une certaine
marginalité ont préféré souvent à les
sécher un cours pour aller dans un
music-hall crasseux voir des familles ça
nous intéressait infiniment plus et je
crois que c'est là que nous avons appris
à interpréter les autres c'est peut-être
les regardons et en délivrant des
contacts avec deux
autres sources d'inspiration la boxe et
les nombreuses réunions organisées à
paris dans l'après guerre
belmondo montre l'exemple sur le ring
ses amis eux le suivent au premier rang
des fauteuils de ring idéal pour éviter
des coûts
moi je n'aimais qu'embrasser
jamais
j'embrasse on était très nourri aussi de
de sa filmographie
américaine oui voilà sur deux sur le
sport la boxe cette baisse de
naturalisme en noir et blanc équipe
exaltant quoi
donc on a on allait voir régulièrement
les matches nous nous imprégnons
extraordinairement des réparties du
public on emmagasine est tout ce qu'ils
nous disaient et c'était un bonheur
formidable c'était c'était aussi fort
pour nous qu'un cours du procès battoir
va donc demander conseil
c'est ça il faut aller au bistrot il
faut aller dans les musées il faut aller
sur le trottoir discuter avec n'importe
qui n'importe quoi n'avoir aucune
conscience de classe sociale et à cela
on peut devenir un acteur
[Musique]
tout le monde craque pour belmondo son
naturel nouvelle vague son regard franc
comme l'or et un sourire désarmant qui
offre en prime bourre pif et baisers
pour cartouches en 62 marielle devait
jouer avec belmondo occupé par ailleurs
ils recommandent gens au producteur
alexandre pouchkine qui cherchent un
comédien cavaliers que mensonges de
belmondo et marielle prenez rochefort il
est très bon à cheval en réalité gens ne
s'est pas encore monté il apprendra en
huit jours cartouche et les chevaux vont
transformer sa vie
je vais prendre des sons j'ai travaillé
comme une brute j'irai faire des nanars
au brésil pour travailler avec nelson
pessoa en dehors des heures de travail
et c'est un coup de foudre
soit de
l'amour du cheval
[Musique]
en 65 un an après le succès de l'homme
de rio belmondo super tintin en
technicolor partage ses tribulations
avec ursula andress et son ami jean qui
l'entraînent jusqu au népal
oui c'est une chouette non monsieur
c'est l'abominable homme des neiges
toile getty le yéti est une sorte de
grand singe triste qui dort debout et
dont le cri ressemble effectivement à ce
qu'il a fait comment savez-vous ça je
les ai lues dans les almanachs monsieur
c'est un homme ou un singe il balance
entre les deux
le confort et l'inconfort aussi d'être
avec jean-paul en pleine lumière alors
que jean lui commence seulement à sortir
de l'ombre
jean-paul c'était le premier qui faisait
craquer les filles qui était un
séducteur le puits alors
quelqu'un qui déboulait quoi avec une
nature nouvelle qui a fait l'unanimité
qu'il y avait une espèce de chose comme
ça est très séducteur est très séduisant
ici un aigrefin vous sautez dessus je
voudrais bien voir ça moi par exemple
[Musique]
je vous cite jamais regarder moi je leur
ai connu à l'époque je pense que toutes
les filles 7 points 2
jean-paul quoi et jean c'est plus le
l'acteur qui a dû exister
voilà en travaillant des rôles en se
faisant remarquer sur des personnages en
n'étant pas forcément
c'est quelqu'un qui a un charme
différents dons qui a dû se faire
connaître différemment et du public et
des cinéastes et des femmes sans doute
et de tous
dans son livre les gens évoquent leur
notoriété à deux vitesses qui amuse
follement edouard baer proche ami de
l'auteur
belmondo signe autographe sur
autographes
apitoyer au monde mandat pour en rire et
par dérision je signe de funès
rapidement autour de moi on se presse je
persiste et signe de funès puis l'amour
propre m'envahir et courageusement je
décide d'utiliser mon patronyme
le récipiendaire
mais qui sait à rochefort c'est moi
soyez gentil signé deux finesse mais
c'est plus un port grec du temps si vous
préférez de funès jumelles de file ps
pour toute cette bande du conservatoire
les marielle et claude rich cremer est
aussi les femmes fabien tout ça je pense
qu'ils étaient stupéfaits parce que
belmondo était comme a sans doute été
bien marlon brando et pour une autre
génération en amérique où james dean
était avait une sorte de il
correspondait à l'époque d'ailleurs y'a
qu'à voir le nombre de gens différents
et elle cherchait comme depardieu l'a
été elle a été après c'était quelqu'un
qui était il marchait partout au pays
dit il on avait envie de le voir sortir
un flingue on avait envie de le voir
chez rennais on à lui de voir chez
godard c'est que comme on avait envie de
devoir de parent du partout c'était
l'époque c'était une sorte de deux
façons d'être voyous dans l'époque ils
ont ils ont ils ont ils ont accepté leur
admiration et quand on admire on n'est
pas jaloux
[Musique]
l'énergie de l'acteur sur les plateaux
comme sur les planches remonte à
l'enfance et s'explique par une
insolente santé dus à la pratique des
sports
datation ping-pong voilà deux sports
faisait pas tiqué en en compétition
une entrée 2 anglaise vraiment avant
gardiste parce que une lesbienne qui
était affirmé le sac à provisions
étaient place de michel m'avait
repéré entre à jouer en bretagne comme
ça à 13o entre ajout ping pong avec un
copain elle avait été championne du
monde deux doubles mixtes hommes et elle
m'a prise normale à la grande colère de
mon père il m'a imposé 2-3 au d'entrer
en vigueur et du terme les
trois heures d'entraînement quotidien
pour faire de moi un immense champion
parce que j'avais quand même un grand
défaut gagner ne m'intéressait pas d
abord
mais qui a été 2e série d'autres on voit
la rue
[Musique]
en 64 la populaire série des angélique
familiariser le grand public avec un
rochefort toujours imberbe l'après midi
il tourne avec robert hossein et michel
mercier et rejoint delphine seyrig le
soir sur les planches du théâtre
hébertot
l'actrice qu'il chérit le plus à deviner
en lui sa fibre tragique elle le grandit
mieux encore les deux complices réalise
un petit exploit qui va enrichir le
répertoire national
qui a fait venir
en france voilà un oui c'est vrai pas
moi seul avec la grande définissent eric
dumas but de la collection les amants
nous avons été bouleversés hausse et
dire on veut jouer ça absolument adore
le contact il nous dit non je ne nous
fait dire je ne veux pas être jeux en
france j'avais eu une mise en scène qui
avait antérieurement beaucoup agacé
alors on le supplie aussi puis je vous
donne une demi heure dans le hall du
sart jose mercredi
à 14 heures après leur vision des
ferries et des ficelles qui pratiquez
l'anglais courant est témoin et nourris
par
des deux mois nous avons essayé de le
conquérir ce qui s'est passé et jade eu
le droit de baisser de pied
jean rochefort jouera une cinquantaine
d'auteurs de théâtre en vrac de molière
à obaldia en passant par giraudoux
pirandello frais sont justes enough j'en
passe
genre il a été aux tempi ya très
longtemps c'était des transats heures
tmp il y avait un charles denner y avait
philippe noiret il y avait maria casarès
geneviève page et amour nombre d'acteurs
et le texte qui a été soufflé c'est mon
père qui a été soufflé rotem paix
pendant très longtemps après avoir été
vingt ans régisseur avec tommy française
et genre me dis à ton père et ça me fait
rire et en même temps mais chez les
rires avec presque des larmes aux yeux
et se souvient tellement bien de mon
père n'est ouvert aux autres ils
s'intéressent année corps de métier dont
on parle pas forcément mais beaucoup de
choses qui me passionnent ya beaucoup de
gens qui me passionne année beaucoup de
d'anonymes qui le passionne heureusement
mais c'est pas
ils en parlent unis veut que ça se sache
et ont fait cas de ces gens là il en
fait des héros parfois
[Musique]
le comédien aime les auteurs nombreux à
saint germain des prés il sympathise
avec les frères prévert croiser boris
vian et lorsqu'il ne joue pas j'en
fréquente les brasseries du quartier
chez lipp notamment où l'oeuvre d'albert
camus prix nobel 57 est décriée par les
censeurs du village
lol tu es considéré par les fleuves de
gauche
dont je ne citerai pas les noms
comme un tronc prolétaires
alors que lui était résidente nous le
comprenions tous
et alors le match qu'on a pu dire de
juillet après sa mort que les autres de
l'intelligentsia
fil de ce fut culturelles françaises ont
pu dire sur lui et c'est là mentale
parce que son côté
modeste automatique classes sociales
modestes d'antiques était tout à coup
trajet enfin c'est irrésistible
non
quels sont les les deux trois auteurs
qui font partie de ton en t on
je peux votre pas citer saisine tu m'as
beaucoup après je lis en ce moment font
douter c'est un auteur américain
extraordinaire où le mal de vivre être
en permanence et dans un style très très
simple bon j'ai relu et relu cervantes
beaucoup beaucoup avant
ce nombre 18 mois
en 75 bertrand tavernier réuni noir et
rochefort et marielle que la fête
commence un petit bijou et pour jean
rochefort le césar du meilleur acteur
dans un second rôle au passage le
récipiendaire en hommage à tavernier il
m'a appris dira-t-il à tutoyer la caméra
il m'a libéré on n'a pas tout l'argent
est protestant mais c'est pour passer 4
et de broc catholiques vont tomber après
deux années de contraintes et
d'hypocrisie bigote c'est le règne de
libertine al assez petit souper on
badine on fait l'amour
ont joué c'est un foutu bordel n'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'il verrait pas et
désordre le régent fait figure de diable
son ministre l'abbé dubois fait figure
de démons un démon qui veut devenir
archevêque normal
la réponse de jean à son frère pierre le
polytechnicien devenu amiral dans la
vraie vie se trouve ici dans la
magistrale interprétation du commandant
de bord rochefort plus vrai que nature
le césar 78 pour son chassé-croisé avec
jacques perrin dans le crabe tambour ou
le scénario est très simple le
commandant que je jouais a promis à
jacques perrin et qui le suivrait qu'il
rentrerait dans dans l'ouest avec lui et
puis j'aimais bien ce jeu mon cas ça
promet le choix de l'homme et pas aux
autres ce qu'il croit finalement
entre le bien et à notre bien il faut
choisir
mais ce type ne poursuivre que de son
kit nord pour sachant que ce personnage
va ouvrir
il présente ses excuses qu'ils avouent
l'autre n'avouera jamais c'est tout sur
lui c'est magnifique c'est la recherche
aussi d'une amitié c'est la recherche
aussi d'une parole donnée une parole
donné ça a été mal géré c'est vrai mais
c'est le fait que l'homme a un certain
mais s'engage et s'engage pour des
causes qui en plus c'est pas s'engager
pour n'importe quoi mais si elles sont
nobles l'homme laisse un sillage
derrière lui merveilleux le jugeait pas
docteur
ne jugez pas qui êtes vous pour le
muguet
croyez vous aussi peut-être qu'il était
innocent j'adore sa façon de jouer sur
la sobriété en fait
l'intériorité tout ce qui tout ce qui se
dégage de lui et qu'ils ne démontrent
pas voilà
ça a été une aventure extraordinaire de
se retrouver marin gortney comme ça du
jour au lendemain et passé deux mois
dans l'atlantique nord ou février je
crois qu'il a rencontré la mère dans le
crabe tambour même si la connaissait
auparavant et qui s'est rendu compte
1ère 2ème jour mon nom de dieu on va lui
jusqu'à terre-neuve ça va nous prendre
combien de temps et quand on sera 4 9
quand tu sais qu'il ya des bruits yahia
la brume sur les hauts plateaux comme ça
de terre-neuve combien de temps va
rester y aura peut-être des moments pour
va pouvoir tourner donc on va rester
d'autant plus sur le tournage on vous
paye plein de vin c'est déjà du rêve
mais avec un bâton dans le bol d'or
la mer vous oblige à une vigilance à un
respect de la mer respect de la mer ça
veut dire que on ne fait pas n'importe
quoi en mer
[Musique]
shawn dorffer était de vianne mort il ya
pas longtemps c'était quand même un
personnage assez étonnant qu'on a accusé
d'ex iii extrême droite mais tout cela
était faux c'est un homme de guerre
mondiale il était journaliste
mais il y avait dans ces vivres et dans
son cinéma une sorte de
2,10 risme douloureux quelques
admirables pourquoi le certains ont
beaucoup aimé les crabes tombeau s'est
pas simplement une histoire de marine
c'est pas une histoire simplement de
marine nationale c'est pas simplement
d'uniformes dans il ya des horizons
c'est quoi les horizons c'est que chacun
rêve de l'endroit où il peut aller au
bout il peut aller c'est presque à la
recherche de soi même parce que là bas
on se retrouve donc il ya besoin de
traverser une épreuve et l'épreuve c'est
la mer
bien sûr que leurs chevaux de la gravité
extraordinaire mais c'est vrai que bon
moi j'aime bien ce côté là j'aime bien
le j'aime bien la légèreté
la légèreté de du personnage développé
avec jean robert haines éléphant ça
trompe énormément
[Musique]
film d'auteur puis films commerciaux
yves robert élargi la palette de genres
avec l'éléphant et nous irons tous au
paradis
c'est une histoire très agité des
démêlés de certains hommes je vous fais
peur ou quoi avec certaines femmes
qui ne sont pas nécessairement une
action digne
troubler les textes de jean loup dabadie
sont taillé sur mesure pour ces dames et
la bande des quatre des quatre copains
dragueur à la maison les mondes son
transistor 38 piges
femme heureuse
yves robert montre tout ce que nous
avons de rigolard douloureux lâche
grotesque et tendre
résultat deux moments de grâce du niveau
de la meilleure comédie italienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis venue de représentants du
français aisés des années soixante dix
présente t elle le site avait un
barbecue une résidence au goût des une
maîtresse il y avait 30 ni chômeurs
et est devenu un peu l'image que ça
c'est des répliques même qui me restent
dedans éléphant ça trompe énormément sa
voix j'en ai tellement non deschanel je
ne dirai pas quand il tape dans le bain
alors qu'il est d'une mauvaise foi
farouche vrai
nom mais surtout aussi
au revoir mon grand quand ils disent
c'est une histoire d'argent non c'est
une histoire d'amour non c'est politique
au revoir mon grand tu fais c'est
réclamé je peux crever oui avec son
imperméable quand ils se planquent alors
qu'on voit depuis
à ton avis c'est le genre de type qui
l'embrassent mains des heures avant de
juger du réel et que je te déchirer
vêtements et que je n'ai visité hier
jean pour inventer on sent que on sent
qu'avec un autre acteur ça n'aurait pas
été la même chose c'est que je viens
c'est 1 1 un acteur insolite tourné en
arabe al nil au roman faute et j'espère
que ma parole de soldat sinon si tu
votes en fait qu'à gauche les algues
géante empêche pas de marché non j'ai
désiré du mérite parce que la vie avec
pépé commencé avec la vie privée moi
j'ai deux ou trois balances car pourquoi
cet intérêt ça ok bras sur jouer au
mieux
la douche débrouille bien et moi je
jouais potable le mans grâce à ma
compétence anti pong mais bedos
mais les problèmes avec ta maman avec
des professionnels
c'est parce qu'il m'a dit c'est lui et
en plus pas réveiller pour me dire de
ville je ne souffre pas je sais pas me
tue pas me raconter cela maintenant
alors je disais donc des démêlés de
certains hommes à part se raconter alors
c'est parti je me suis présenté chez toi
il faut l'empêcher de rentrer dans son
cabinet
[Musique]
je reste un éléphant
ça trompe énormément
[Musique]
les gens à quitter paris et ses pièges
pour vivre avec ses chevaux
entre deux tournages il soigne monte
élèves à leur contact dit-il l'on
apprend à faire moins pour obtenir plus
comme dans la comédie
éleveur quasi professionnel il est
toujours présent lors des naissances et
aidera une trentaine de ses juments à
mettre bas
cet animal est
exceptionnel quoi un mouvement une
prière je suis un homme à crottin
couanau l'odeur du cheval les réactions
du cheval la jument que j'ai mis au
monde moi même et qui quand elle va
mettre bas me fait comprendre que ça va
venir qui me tant qu'il ne qui se
retourne pour que je vois bien sa vue et
les deux petits sabots intérieur qui
vous sortir pour que je tire c'est quand
même une pépite dans la vie d'un homme
je le vois très bien la nuit comme ça
embrouiller sa famille dort il a dit non
moi je vais rester à l'écurie avec eux
avec eux avec fuji terme à ma jument b
je vais attendre la nuit calme et bages
le voici dans la paille comme celle-là
regardant le lire bah ma vie' c'est
thomas la mort aux rats
l'éleveur jean rochefort est à l'origine
de la première transplantation
européenne d'embryons chez une jument
une implication qui lui vaut le mérite
agricole la seule récompense dont ils
soient vraiment fier quand il a vu que
raffarin était à moins 8 dans les
sondages est elle un peu politique le
moins populaire de la vème république
avant françois hollande il est s'est
empressé lui demandez lui remettre son
mérite agricole tout s'est passé les
gangs de monter à la politique le moins
populaire de france de lui remettre la
seule médaille qui trouvait un petit peu
digne et puisqu'il préfère être connus
comme éleveur de chevaux comme acteur
une réussite qui entraînait un lien
inattendu avec les grands de ce monde
soirée de gala à l'elysée il dit dans
petit comité avec un ris kissinger et la
reine d'angleterre un moment jusqu'à 10
majesté jean rochefort n'est pas
seulement un acteur reconnu en france où
jamais il est également cavaliers
éleveurs de chevaux et adore elle me
pose une question très matoise
disant ah bon avec une certaine
indifférence
et je lui réponds oui majesté j'étais
très heureux de voir votre fille gagner
des championnats d'europe ce jour là
alors là la glace s'est brisée s'est
brisé et la bête et moi nous avons parlé
très longuement de chevaux puisque
c'était un sujet qui la passionnait plus
et autant que moi donc nous avons un
coup de d'affections comme eux comme des
joueurs de foot qu elle nous est pas
qu'il soit bon et c'était une soirée
sur l'honneur et wattrelos
au micro d'equidia et de france
télévisions le commentateur rochefort
fait un tabac lors des grands événements
équestres son regard et son expertise
ici sur un couple champion du monde et
champion olympique jean teulère et sans
cheval espoir
le monde qui me vient à l esprit à tout
va tout c'est le mot foudre à quelque
chose d'assez foudroyant
dans son énergie dans ces départs
c'est la rencontre de la foudre et du
câble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
djibo laisse au double
aliochine jean rochefort et ils l'acteur
phare de la carrière de patrice leconte
et vice versa sept films les races en
tandem tourné en 87 raconte l'émouvante
fin de carrière d'un animateur radio
lâché par sa direction comme boulot est
là
quand il écoute le téléphone et qui fait
semblant d'appeler pour la 1ère fois sa
compagne et qu'on s'aperçoit au bout
d'un moment c'est vers l'âge parlante le
rôle est magnifique pour lui parce qu'il
a 7
les espoirs les gens solaire comme ça
mais
c'est surtout le film du début de notre
histoire d'amour puisque le tout premier
film avait été une catastrophe de
rapports humains qui grinçait beaucoup
qu'on s'était pas vue pendant ce temps
je sais pas 10 12 ans et que quand j'ai
fait tandem ça a été non retrouvées
c'est là qu'a commencé notre histoire et
je soutiendrai toujours il a le le goût
des formules à l'emporte-pièce et en se
référant à notre premier film qui
n'avait pas été très confortable il
m'avait dit tu vois patrice on a
commencé par notre pain noir et
maintenant c'est notre pain blanc
j'en ai pas quelqu un qui mâche ses mots
est qui et qui fait les choses sans
réfléchir genre il a besoin de
s'investir totalement dans les tournages
par exemple dans les voiles qu'il
incarne tout à coup il faut que tout
soit clair il faut que tu aies il faut
qu'il admire le metteur en scène qu'il a
en face de lui quelqu'un torrentielles
soit habité par son par son film parce
que lui même a une grande exigence
j'en avais mis au point d'être très
instinctive une espèce de de jeu avec
les mains comme ça il dit
il y avait un plan et disait alors j'ai
fait ça et ces caravanes je te promets
il va les vendre et je le serai toujours
gérard jugnot fond c'était parmi les
premiers jours de tournage et jugnot lui
dit mais jean tu comptes tous jouer en
faisant ça tout le film mais petit et
amicales et jean a eu cette réponse
génial yali t'inquiète pas coco c'est
bosser
one on l'avait bien corps
compte tenu
du temps
[Musique]
eh bien
les grands
dans le mari de la coiffeuse je les
entraînais sur un terrain qui ne lui
convenait pas et il a fallu que je force
un peu qui était le terrain sentimentale
et jean et en étant un homme de cheval
n'est pas un sentimental et il craignait
terriblement de plongée dans une espèce
de guimond de trucs un peu mièvre ils
craignent et de
de couler dans quelque chose de facile
ou de trop aquarelles et sa grande sa
grande revanche sur le sur le rôle qui
effectivement été sentimentale
sa grande revanche c'était ces moments
que moi j'aimais par contraste
évidemment ces moments de danse
arabisante folle
quand on enjambe à ce point la crainte
du ridicule on atteint ont subi
et
le rire et les larmes en 2004 l'hommage
de gens à son compagnon des trois
baudets l'ami fernand raynaud morts sur
la route trente ans plus tôt
[Musique]
cet ouvrier de chez michelin qui
rentre dans une bétaillère avec sa rolls
royce est une
si le problème c'est qu'ils avaient fait
rentrer deux jours
le pianiste bruno fontaine jouer erik
satie
compositeur génial et désespérés comme
l'était fernand raynaud
dans ce cousinage saugrenue j'en
reprends les meilleurs sketches de
l'artiste est ici
le fameux plombier et le perroquet de
madame mouchabeurre
[Musique]
qui sait ses plombiers
tu sais c'est tombiez
kessel
7 janvier 17
le toucher
je lis très bien connu pierre dont
toujours le cabaret et c'était un homme
profondément triste professionnellement
malheureusement tous ces sketches il
était une victime ils gagnaient jamais
et c'est toujours vous rallier par la
société ma bouche à bouche suit l'envié
on est plombier deux fils et en terre
chez nous au travail on y plombier je
suis à ploguer schéma choix de vivre à
moi c'est mon bonheur moi
tu sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous faites là qu'est ce que
vous voulez on vous le fait pour la
moitié voilà la moitié de quoi moitié
prix dans les grands ducs de patrice
leconte toujours rochefort retrouve ses
complices je suis dit noir et et le
phénoménal jean pierre marielle
faramineuse des conditions à savoir
combien ces trois noms qui font partie
de la distribution des professionnels
[Musique]
moi je voulais vraiment faire un
tournage qu'il ya 250 à l'heure pour pas
leur laisser le temps de souffler pour
qu'il soit tout le temps dans une espèce
d'énergie parce que sinon alors ils
s'asseyaient il prenait il se raconter
des anecdotes et le film n'avançait pas
donc il fallait tout le temps dès qu'ils
poser leurs fesses je leur
demandais de l'élever pour tourner
[Musique]
djouhri pourquoi ce qui m'a touché
infiniment avait que 3 c'est que quand
certaines scènes étaient joués par l'un
ou par deux mais pas par les trois ce
qui n'était pas du plan était tout le
temps à côté de la caméra pour regarder
ses copains jouer et ça et il y avait de
la gourmandise chez eux est d'ailleurs à
ce sujet
philippe noiret m'avait un jour dit un
truc qui m'a percé le coeur
il n'était pas du plan et c'était un
plan avec marielle et rochefort
et noir et les regarder avec une espèce
d'admiration et dans ofi comme ça puis
m'a pris par la manche qui m'a dit vous
voyez patrice
jean et jean pierre ils ont quelque
chose que je n'aurais jamais la folie
ah ah
novembre 2006 disparition de philippe
noiret ensemble ils ont joué au tnp
tourner des films partager une amitié
secrète est calme fait de déjeuner de
passion commune pour les voitures
anglaises et l'élégance british
toujours sapé comme des princes où ça
boulet comme des voyous
[Musique]
chez noir est il y avait parallèlement à
son goût pour l'art dramatique théâtre
et cinéma il y avait le goût des
matières et il y avait le blues des
artisanats il était capable de passer
deux heures
parmi des artisans succès de cuir qu'ils
aient des fleurs ou n'importe quoi
d'autre des bouquets et s'y intéresser
passionnément c'était l'amour de la
matière
c'est à dire une chose totalement
sincère
[Musique]
le goût des mots gens là depuis toujours
il écrit comme il joue sans verbiage
mais avec malice en compagnie du
critique d'art edward vigneault il se
lance dans le louvre à cheval délire de
peintures de sculptures et d'écriture
[Musique]
les trois chevaux de delacroix sont dans
des stalles quel regret que ces oeuvres
ne soit pas olfactives quoi de plus
délicieux que l'odeur du foin de la
paille et des chevaux
alors je pense que
tu y as eu un petit peu le crottin quand
même c'est une grille de lecture du
monde voit sur cette âme au rallye c'est
quelqu'un qui qui est qu elle qui a une
vision de la vie que c'est d'ailleurs il
ya quand il parle c'est extraordinaire
parce qu'il parle vraiment pas fort
hills moi c'est quelqu'un dont les
phrases reste c'est à dire que j'ai un
nombre de phrases dans ma tête le genre
m'a dit comme ça au détour de l'une dans
une situation où ça m'est toujours resté
par exemple quand il m'a dit un jour
changent on n'achète jamais le barbecue
puis ça fait le chemin et puis
finalement on comprend que son achète et
barbecue en acheter la maison de
campagne de la compagnie les traite donc
on se met à faire des films pour payer
les traites et un seul agent n'importe
quoi chacune deux chefs de ses phrasés
et une flèche très très très précise et
je trouve ça merveilleux de de lier ce
ce talent ce refus cette autodérision
qui évidemment toujours quand même une
des choses les plus importantes dans la
vie qui permet de s'en sortir même dans
les mêmes quand on arrive droit dans le
mur to talk on peut tourner par
l'autodérision
b / humaines et professionnelles de ce
rochefort don quichotte survenue en 2000
il apprend l'anglais à 70 ans pour
tourner avec johnny depp et le
réalisateur anglais terry gilliam
[Musique]
forme directe obtenant 10 étoiles maquis
ce
côté
budget production insuffisant
va-et-vient d'avions de chasse tempête
de sable pluies torrentielles et pour
achever le tout jean rochefort est
victime d'une double hernie discale
l'homme de cheval ne montera plus jamais
le film ne se fera pas mais accouche
d'un making of qui témoigne de la
vengeance de cervantès sur le
réalisateur
je me suis consolé consoler et johnny
depp et c'est un ami et simple d'accord
avec moi le jazz et folk au but je crois
qu'on aurait fait un mauvais climat
pourquoi parce que notre mettront en
scène
terry gilliam qui a fait un très beau
film s'appelait brasil après dijon sont
discutables était quand même un fana des
effets spéciaux
on avait un coude relève
robinson
et je trouvais quand on relit cervantes
qu'ils aient absolument nous poser sa
toute vérité pour l'ue et oui il y avait
un hiatus énorme et on était très mal
par
le malaise est totale la production
avait affamés rossinante pour plus de
vraisemblance
[Musique]
le cheval est mort peu après jean
l'apprendra de retour à paris il en fera
une dépression
[Musique]
je le sais je le sens extrêmement
bouleversée par les chevaux et c'est
quelque chose qui m'intrigue de lui
puisque moi je
ne vis pas ça donc ça m'intrigue la
façon dont tu parles des chevaux on a
façon non tine on sait habite sa vie et
ça
c'est très important pour lui
longtemps avant le drame le cheval qui
lui a tant donné a bien failli tout lui
reprendre au point de le laisser dans la
dèche sur le trottoir
j'avais besoin de nourrice ou une fois
d'énergie un huissier dans ma cour de ma
ferme cd failli écraser mon fils pierre
je suis en colère je sors d'une halle
enquête vous j'avais pu écraser monfils
qu'est ce que vous donne son nom il me
dit je suis initié je viens saisir vos
shows
48 heures après coup de téléphone est ce
que ça vous intéresserait de vente et le
café machin mais voilà j'ai dit oui tout
de suite évidemment aimé chevaux sont
restés à la maison
le milieu lui reproche de faire des pubs
à la télé de vendre son âme au diable
pour nourrir ses chevaux et continuer
l'élevage il s'en fout cette pub réalisé
par delphine gleize rejoint son
obsession de toujours la fascination du
chimpanzé
écoute lapin qui est pas complètement
abrutis alors dis-moi pourquoi ça marche
idtgv
j'ai une association artistique et
affective avec delphine gleize qui était
jeune femme mettre en scène nous avons
fait d'ailleurs en commun film qui
s'appelait cavalier seul et nous avons
eu le même esprit très longtemps
cette publicité a été typiquement
delphine et
moi même
second mais il ya un esprit que konami
allô maman allô maman je peux pas te
parler c'est un peu compliqué
en fait j'avais une copine en fait je te
rappelle à temps est ce que tu sais
pourquoi ça marche toi idtgv
ok d'accord
au mal et laisse tomber qu'est ce
qu'elle va qui consent fond pourquoi ça
marche ça marche c'est tout
trop bien
des filles visas sont utiles trouvera
pourquoi sa base touche finale un an
didier chenet gratos raconte
alan
doss
[Musique]
la main tendue de gens au jeune comédien
et réalisateur qu'il invite à faire leur
premier film est fréquent
dans ce milieu égocentrique rares sont
les grands qui comme jean rochefort ont
tracé un large cercle autour d'eux
je vous propose un stage de formation de
six semaines comprenant différentes
cibles pierre salvadori qui entraîne
guillaume depardieu dans la foulée d'un
rochefort tueur à gages
samuel benchetrit dont l'humour tu met
c'est pour de faux
j'ai toujours rêvé d'être un gangster
réuni toute la jeune garde du cinéma
français
edouard baer héritier spirituel de jean
et braqueur au pistolet à eau bon bah je
suis honnête
je découpe beaucoup nous téléphonons
très souvent
un immense talent je veux qu'ils
éclatent avant que je ne quitte le globe
voilà je suis très attentif à ce qu'il
fait ce qu'il désire et ce qu'ils
recherchent je n'ai vu à au théâtre de
l'atelier d'hier modiano ceux des plus
grands moments un des grands moments
d'émotion que j'ai joué au théâtre dans
ma vie c'est vraiment beaucoup de moral
de l'appeler genre je passe je sais pape
est vraiment je peux être très au bout
du rouleau et lui aussi est normalement
les deux énergies négatif et dans l'ain
positif et ben nous sic oil on rit
chaque alors on ride d'abord nos
problèmes en sus des plaintes de l'autre
donc s'il est très mal je ne vous
inquiétez pas vous allez bientôt effacée
vous inquiétez pas les vos espérances de
vie à 82 ans ne sont pas plus de dix ans
donc ça me fait beaucoup rire moi aussi
je parle de mes premiers mois il me dit
que toute façon macaire est une
catastrophe que j'ai encore que je
remplis dans les pentes l ongle donc on
est très contents de s'insulter c'est un
camarade un ami de bon aloi et de bonnes
fréquentations
wild vraiment toutes les études
de la miss est qu'on imagine au 19e
siècle un peu nous avons des
conversations obscènes ou délicieusement
moudden il est universel quoi il a un
côté depardieu c'est qu'on peut partir
de la terre on peut passer on remonte
par le corps humain les problèmes de
douleurs au genou on peut repasser par
le sexe son pari mais on peut le rester
un moment dans l'estomac et les méandres
des premiers cestino et puis on peut
ressortir par le choeur par les
sentiments la vie amoureuse l'âme la
l'immortalité de vous l'envoyer de 3
vacheries raconter des choses qui nous
ont plu en fin de mai tout et du coq à
l'âne c'est vrai qu'on ce que moi je me
reconnais dans son dans son esprit dans
sa façon de voir les choses il n'y a pas
de frontières d'un agent et moi là je
m'en fiche je suis avec jean comme avec
un homme de mon âge parce qu'il a cette
jeunesse en lui parce que et c'est comme
si c'était un homme aussi jeune que moi
mais plein de souvenirs et d'histoires à
raconter
puisque finalement il l'a
de 40 ans de plus que moi mais
c'est un homme aussi jeune que moi si
vous voulez donc qu' il se rapproche de
ce
qu'il pense lui ressembler faire avec
qui il a des affinités
les chevaux encore eux provoque la
rencontre entre guillaume canet bons
cavaliers amateurs et l'éleveur jean
rochefort
d'abord il y avait le personnage que je
voyais en concours quand j'étais gamin
et qui était jean rochefort l'acteur que
moi je vénérais et je voyais en concours
d'une simplicité puis dans son dans son
élément quoi qui est qui arrêtait pas de
come on connaît quoi qui est très très
volubile très très très sympathiques
comme ça avec beaucoup de charisme
[Applaudissements]
et puis j'ai eu cette rencontre
formidable avec lui un jour où il est
venu chez mon père avoir une jument qui
avait publié chez chez mon père et c'est
là que c'est vrai que la rencontre a été
formidable il m'a dit mais les tigers à
faire du cinéma et jeux d'image fait du
théâtre des téléfilms et il gare mais je
le savais et il me dit tu vas faire un
film avec moi
[Musique]
je lui dois tout parce que ce film m'a
permis d'en faire d'autres à l'époque la
télé n'était pas très bien vu au cinéma
et que je faisais des téléfilms du
théâtre mais que j'arrivais pas des
prochains rôles au cinéma et c'est un
très bon rôle et qu'on a eu une
complicité normes sont ce tournage s'il
n'est pas là peut-être que guillaume
canet ne devient jamais comédiens ni
réalisateur enfin ils doivent bientôt du
sud et d'asie ont fait ça n'ont qu'un
autre serait passé qui aurait fait un
cardiaque il fait maintenant longtemps
que le connaître apple et ses produits
réplique dans barracuda j'ai eu
l'impression de jouer avec une ferrari
quoi
[Musique]
je sais j'suis pas encore publiquement
gars que tu veux vous savez bien ça fait
trois mois que je travaille ici faites
un petit effort commence m'appelle
floride sorti en août 2015 est une main
tendue une de plus cette fois
réalisateur philippe le guay il a
convaincu jean de jouer une octogénaire
en proie aux difficultés de l'âge
sandrine kiberlain que l'on sait proche
de jean est excellente dans le rôle de
sa fille
[Musique]
le film s'est monté au pied de l'opéra
comique comme pour saluer celui dont
l'humour fait des ravages depuis 85 ans
nouvel exploit de l'acteur qui a toute
sa tête et qui joue l'opposé
[Musique]
on comprend font que cet homme perd un
peu la tête qu'il a il a des trous des
absences il a des oublis et et en
attendant il se reprend voilà c'est
quelqu'un c'est un personnage qui est
alternatif tantôt présente absent avec
parfois des bouffées de violence tu vas
vous prévenir mon père aime pas trop
l'idée d'avoir quelqu'un pour l'aider
vous avez eu le tort de prendre cette
place elle va pas très bien quand vous
allez mourir j'ai l'habitude avec la
personne vieille dame et arrête
maintenant tu fais chier on se dit pas
son papa des choses comme ça mais vous
savez quoi adopté le je vous laisse vous
avez vu comment le choc face à
moi j'ai partagé ça avec lui sur ton âge
qui était sapeur de 2,2
d'endosser ce rôle
qui racontait quelque chose de pas si
loin de lui en tout cas qu'ils pouvaient
se rapprocher de lui ou de ses proches
ce qu'il avait aussi en tête beaucoup
certains de ses proches et de raconter
ça cet homme qui équipent mollahs qui
vieillit qui perd la tête qui peut être
à la fois cruelle à la fois drôle et à
la fois dur et ans et
il voulait l'aborder avec le plus de
sincérité possible pour ne pas trahir
ceux qui pourraient vivre ça réellement
quelque chose nous
ça suffit
quand on se connaît aussi et beaucoup de
pudeur de part et d'autre sinon des
scènes aussi extrêmes que celles là que
la maladie que je me changeais son père
quand il vient de se faire pipi dessus
et c'est pas non plus c'est pas si c'est
nous qu'on appréhende ou pas d'ailleurs
mais qui sur le moment bon ça soit on
est pareil j'en ai fait moi sur un film
on se lance la fois donc il a été
chercher au plus profond de lui-même
et en même temps on savait tous lui et
moi et toutes les personnes de l'équipe
que c'était un rôle c'est toujours ce
paradoxe extraordinaire de la vérité
foin du mensonge
aujourd'hui du haut de son balcon
jean peut interroger sans rougir le
jeune rochefort qu'il était à 18 ans
à la question que tu fait de ton talent
nous avons tous la réponse
quelques nanars qu'il confesse en se
marrant
et déchets d'heure sur le nombre
difficile de faire le tri mais
impossible d'oublier polly maggoo bruno
sur l'arrogance des gens de télé calmos
comédie poil à gratter en plein
mouvement féministe le cavaleur jolie
petite musique de chambre l'homme du
train johnny et jean entendra savent ni
ridicule enfin avec ses dialogues
ciselés et planté au cordeau
mais pour des millions d'enfants et pour
gabriela neuf ans le moustachu marrant
c'est le copain de winnie l'ourson
bourriquet tigre où elle retrouve encore
dans titeuf qu'elle adore puis gabriela
la démasquer aussi dans jack et la
mécanique du coeur
[Musique]
à plus de 85 ans jean rochefort n'a
toujours pas renoncé à ses audaces
l'artiste et son modèle par exemple de
renvoi en noir et blanc des premiers
films tournés à saint-lunaire
jean rochefort magistral s'est beaucoup
inspiré du sculpteur paul belmondo le
père de jean paul dont il a fréquenté
l'atelier et d'alberto giacometti
cet aîné croisé à saint germain des prés
nous avons tous dans le coeur un film
avec jean rochefort
si d'aventuré vous le croisez dans la
rue il sera amical est toujours prêt à
secouer le pot-au-feu vous serez surpris
par sa jeunesse ses contre-pieds en
basket citron on aura compris que ce
dandy fait les est avant tout pudique et
profond
à j 6 avr oui c'est ça ou d'enfants de 2
14 ans des cours
que nous sommes aussi des monstres
des monstres et j'ai vu des choses
horribles
et ça m'a marqué profondément
toute ma vie il sonnera comme ces
tapis de jeunes fuient et puis on pisse
sur leur sésame
selon mon âge et je ne suis donc un zoo
dont alors c'est resté tout le temps
dans la tête toute ma vie ça ne va pas
mieux
ça continue c'est presque de pire en
pire
qu'est-ce qu'on devient qu'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire ce qu'on est en
train de détruire pour presque nulle
autre
c'est un enjeu
ça me rend beaucoup j'ai des enfants
nous avons tous des enfants on peut soit
m'inquiéter
je vois toujours cette phrase de ce
style dans l'idiot
pourquoi les hommes ne s'embrassent t-il
pas
biologiquement
on nous a pas construit comme ce
problème
se fait un peu sérieux tout ce que je
raconte ça fait partie de mes
préoccupations
avant de faire ma valise mais si cette
coupe qui se trouvent trop sérieux pour
moi sanaa